I know that with any movie you do you do
a lot of development work with your
character and you have a big presence
but limited screen time here so I'm
wondering does the same apply for a role
like this absolutely you have to you
have to go whatever part you have as
well they're no small parts today and as
you will learn is this develops you will
understand that no you have to build a
backstory for your character you gotta
know who they are where they come from
what they want and of course I did all
that I mean I've been in this business
almost over 25 years and I still have
fun
I wake up actually not well I don't
worry anymore about when the work is
coming but I actually wonder who's gonna
call me first and then I go about my day
whether it's cooking tentative garden
took care of my cats just life's tough
and then when I get the call then I can
jump into it and be quite excited you're
a cat lover yeah we have three that
makes me admire you even more yeah I do
I have a cat and that cat is I treat it
like a child do you do I thought every
since I was eight we've had a cat
somewhere in my household curious first
guys well my first gotten it was named
zippy current cat Charlie Parker
who's the female we didn't know she was
a female until okay and then Sparky
sparks his middle cat and cat daddy Nico
was my okay is that tuxedo is that then
obviously you celebrated a film watching
Candyman over and over and seeing a
whole lot of your work you know you you
play pretty imposing characters are you
hanging with cats is bringing a whole
lot of joy to my life remember this I
was a person first and a human being
second and I know the difference between
fantasy feasts and fiscal switching your
love right could you just when they
think we got it figured out boom just
like a good horror that the other day oh
yeah the switch over I stood with a new
flavor
they love that to help as much as I love
cats can you tell me a little bit about
some of the backstory you came up with
yeah well I'm the guy that owns and has
created this particular attraction that
travels from city to city you know every
season and I know a bunch of real-life
haunted trots and people have talked to
them I mean if you're successful at it
they make their living in those two
months you know the end of August
through Halloween if it's done well and
in this particular case we're so
particular to the detail of our actors
who are inside the maze greatness chills
and the drills that perhaps who did it
too well and someone is able to
infiltrate our ranks so having already
talked to Gregory and and go you know I
know if it's successful you have plans
to move on to continue it's a perfect
type of franchise and I've been pretty
lucky with those you know that you had
there's another one of my favorites
final destination so I just had a
conversation Jeffrey Redick today and
it's Susan - the anniversary is
something close by he's got a new film
called the final wish wait they were
talking about is strongly two years
though these rumors about everything I
don't know like the dark ages or
something like that really an idea what
I am happy about though is to hear we're
getting more candy and yeah and I'm
gonna be talking about it before that
you would be open to the idea of them
continuing it or maybe
because even if I'm not involved that
they do it and just gonna put more
attention on the original you know I
mean I don't know how many copies I've
signed I've lost count of two million I
don't have enough energy to sign two
million of anything the one that does
mystify me the Candyman towels Oh
todd mcfarlane created when I signed a
contract senators only $1,000 and know
for a fact that doesn't matter
even though you could give one piece of
advice to the filmmakers behind this new
Candyman film what would it be well I've
heard the Jordan Peele as a fan not only
of the character but his walk and an
eyes paps I just wanted to be honest to
the source and to make sure if you come
up for new wrinkle
you got a came in is a different type of
cat you know just make sure it has the
right social connotations and that
people take it too seriously not too
serious movie and when I say serious
with the respect that it deserves
that's all I ask and you know I'm sure
I'll get a crumb or two from the table
one way any whether I want you to just
be in a passing of the baton I can't
predict the future but I'm sure
something Jordan has such a respect
where the word has come before I mean
two of his films at night Living Dead
week ending up so I got a small piece of
bone and now it's Hellfest
[Music]